qui a le droit de ne pas se faire
vacciner pour patrick gohet la réponse
est claire personne alors qu'il était en
concert à bruxelles jeudi dernier le
chanteur en a profité pour prendre la
parole au sujet de l'épidémie de
coronavirus
mais surtout pour faire la morale aux
non vaccinés
vous avez vu ce qu'avait dit christine
boutin christine boutin non mais
franchement christine boutin c'est faux
lieu je suis très très inquiet je
m'interroge sur la dénomination du
nouveau variant au micron est ce une
blague ou un mot proche du patronyme du
président pour que ce mot soit cerisaie
plusieurs fois pas à nos oreilles
jusqu'aux présidentielles rassurez moi
j'ai mal compris non vous n'avez pas mal
compris vous étiez juste en train de
cuver christine on ne peut pas l'ignorer
la proximité de sonorités entre au micro
et un affront
pour mac donc du coup donc du coup
effectivement ça c'est la mort est
ouverte à tout un tas de blague c'est
drôle ou pas droit bon ben ça c'est
autre chose que soient ouvertes mais bon
c'est le seul offensive intellectuelle
c'est une news valeurs actuelles le
figaro mais il faut regarder les choses
de sang il précisé mais il faut regarder
les choses ces médias la faune
bondissant de paris-charles de ddt
histoire de paris où les gens les gens
qui les jouisseurs de paille et
j'entends les gens disent ils en ont
ras-le-bol et joie sort deux ténors tous
les olives les gentils lors de tes
places
j'ai pu me procurer et là vous allez
être fier de moi la première échographie
du futur bébé zemmour la voici
oui il a déjà le doigté ça t'a pas car
oui évidemment ce week end eric zemmour
était à marseille et il a montré toute
l'étendue de sa rhétorique lorsqu'une
dame l'a interpellé sans doute voulant
lui parler proctologie un président
peut-il faire un beau d'honneur à une
passante qu'est ce qu'on imagine le
général de gaulle faire un doigt
d'honneur
imagine-t-on le jeu qui propulse le
général de gaulle dans toutes les
situations
le général de gaulle adressé un doigt
d'honneur qui imagine le général de
gaulle faire un doigt d'honneur à une
femme
le général de gaulle aurait t'il fait un
geste pareil les scènes général qui est
ce que françois hollande aurait fait la
même chose
a déjà le toit qui sortent sont doivent
au sol ont
quand même l'homme le moins rapide
qu'en soit le temps qu'il fasse abattre
les france follath à la tête de ma mère
déjà eto'o qui lâche le cake qu'il a
dans la main
je
lui dis je lai dans le pif il n'y a pas
d'âge pour se révolter ça se passe au
bon saint martin en moselle où les
élèves du collège se sont mobilisés pour
déguster leur plat préféré un groupe
d'élèves a interpellé la direction du
collège avec une lettre placardées sur
les murs de l'établissement je les cite
collégienne collégiens de nos jours le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas de raclette à la
cantine est devenu banal accepté de tous
et c'est un scandale
[Musique]
ils ont transformé un moment pénible en
un clip amusant
c'est
bloqué hier soir sur l'a 89 pendant
plusieurs heures un groupe d'amis à
passer le temps en composant une chanson
de circonstance semi-remorque renversé
une dépanneuse bien bloqué sur
l'autoroute de montluçon j'ai des
glaçons dans quatre centres ou tiendront
tête à tout le personnel et chanteront
jusqu'au bout le refrain de la raclée
alors c'est quoi la suisse où ils
écrivent les paroles en chaussettes ou
en claquettes j'aime la raclette avec
elle c'est la fête j'aime la raclette
voilà ce qu'écrit le collectif qui
signent rer c rires et raclette chantant
la
légion cet arrêt aurait bon d'accord
mais
quand le
saivet tout le monde appelle
l'église il veut donc j'aime sais pas
je peux le répéter
[Musique]
cramer on dirait que
je viens de brûler le chap
[Musique]
ça sent ça sent la poule l adéquation
le principal a répondu en affichant à
son tour une lettre sur les murs de
l'établissement il écrit je cite la
direction après concertation avec elle
même donne un avis favorable à cette
demande à une condition entendre une
délégation d'élèves entonnait le refrain
de la raclette murat cour de récréation
conditions remplies immédiatement à les
membres du collectif rires athlètes ont
chanté dans la cour devant tous leurs
camarades
on est dans le caca on est dans le mur
quand on affiche sa
catégorie
[Musique]
écoutez c'est très mignon tout bon voilà
on est bien noël ces cinq screenshots
giving jour de la pintade de la dinde un
it's not noël prendre l'existence d'une
love [__] et franchement je suis
content parce que j'adore le lord et
beach interwievé confiante au speed
dating oui moi aussi j'étais confiant
mais s'est pas trompé tous mes rêves se
sont réalisés avec toi et j'avais rêvé
d'aller nous sommes à limoges
les prix de l'immobilier flambent aussi
dans les univers virtuels comme des
centrales hand une société a récemment
débourser 2,4 millions de dollars pour
s'offrir 565 mètres carrés de parcelles
de terrain virtuel des pixels à prix
d'or plus de 3700 euros le mètre carré
c'est à peu près le prix de l'immobilier
dans une ville comme toulouse les
investisseurs espère louer ou revendre
ces espaces virtuels à des marques bien
réel
après j'ai avec son temps maintenant il
ya des sapins superficial donc pas bon
de quoi la première question que j'ai
posée c'est elle la vraie mère noël et
je lui demandais si l évier pas virer le
père noël
je ne peux pas virer le père noël c'est
mon ami je le connais non une vidéo non
c'est vrai on se voit chaque année ils
voient les enfants apprennent ensemble
ils mangent des cookies il ne boit pas
d'alcool en revanche
avec elle ferait préfère faire et
refaire faire quoi toi
+ moi j'ai toujours dit la mort abolie
l'amour quoi l'amour à bolelli la mort
mobile et
l'amour embolie à huy d'arrivants
c'est tout à fait vrai